I looked at my husband and he's like no
don't take the shot but I had it on me
and if he would have said take the shot
I would have taken the shot and
ultimately probably would have ended
that guy's life one of the towns where I
lived between 1st and 6th grade was
Newtown Connecticut and obviously people
know that name you know the Sandy Hook
shooting I used to have to explain even
the people from Connecticut where
Newtown was and now it's like oh my god
my father when I was a small child was
shot and he lost his leg 37 years ago
this happened because I was still an
infant and he's still affected by that
day and then my sister has lost to her
husband so my brothers and laws have
both died by gun violence me personally
around Tom a high school I was DJing at
a party and you know there were some
people there were part of X gang and
then Y gang comes in they get into
altercation physical and then the next
thing you know somebody leaves comes
back with a weapon they're shooting I
duck I come back up after they've
already left the party by the time I
looked behind me there was a bullet
round like the bullet hole right behind
me like literally if I had not done that
that rights on when they started
shooting it could have been meant for me
I definitely feel lucky standing on this
line and I can't imagine going through
it you and your families went through it
just I I just can't
three two
I'm from Phoenix Phoenix we're very open
about gun ownership and whatnot coming
to California which I do regularly I
know the law is here and I can't
necessarily bring my firearms with me so
I have to have other tools at my
disposal sometimes I'll use
less-than-lethal sometimes they'll have
training and situational awareness like
evidences and science to look for it I
live neighborhood and so it's very
very imperative that you protect
yourself by any means
I say somewhat agree in the sense that
if it were a physical altercation I feel
you know with my military and martial
arts background that I would be able to
protect myself but at the same time that
can't stop somebody else with a gun or
somebody else with you know efficient
means to take my life or take my
family's life so and crime happens
everywhere what I hope happens nice
places of Orange County just recently
like in the afternoon on a Wednesday
people are being stabbed and I think a
lot has to do with Prop 47 where we have
the overcrowded prison overcrowded jails
it's like a revolving door people commit
crime they high-five the jails and
they're out back on the streets and
we're just supposed to be okay and not
be armed like that's why I have a hard
time with let's say I agree with you but
I also understand that like when you
live in suburban neighborhoods you are
afforded the privilege of more
protection in certain residences it's
supposed to where I live at where it's
pretty much a free-for-all for anybody
who wants to take your stuff
I'm not a one-issue voter so if it's
like if I agree with someone on nine
things but they disagree with me on the
second amendment or guns I'm still gonna
vote for them even if they're trying to
disarm you
you'll still vote for them what I would
try to do within you know left-leaning
politics is make my voice heard and try
to temper that as best I can I think my
time in the military forced me to look
at both sides of spectrum liberal and
conservative and I think there's a gross
misinterpretation saying that all
liberals want to ban guns and I feel
like we need to express the dialogue
individually and not necessarily rely on
the media to basically stimulate the
direction of the conversation for us or
you're supposed to be this way or you're
not supposed to be this way I feel like
since coming out as transgender the fact
that the right has been trying to
actively put me down and put me into a
hole has made me become a lot
disenfranchised with them I used to
consider myself a conservative before I
came out and it's just hard because I
don't feel like I've shifted all that
much in my beliefs I just feel like the
political spectrum and discourse has
shifted so far to the right that now I
happen to stand on the left
as a firearms instructor I've had so
much support from the NRA there's so
much available yes the NRA has a lot of
resources for instructors however when
it comes to black to black Second
Amendment is completely different than
people who don't look like me and we've
noticed that they've been silent on the
sidelines when people who look like me
our responsible gun owners are carrying
concealed they were silent if the NRA
leadership were to change if their
priorities were to get more in order I
would most likely be on your side again
I would but they're not this is where
the change starts is is us having a
conversation in us being in a position
to make that change start to trickle
uphill correct and like a lot I said
before with a lot of the leadership
leaving and tendering their resignations
and whatnot
if that causes an actual shake-up and
I'm excited that it will but if it
actually does and it does come to
fruition
sure
sorry I went to the wrong I should have
been over there should I just stay here
okay
I've never had to pull it out I say for
me I stand in someone agree because
there was a home invasion I wouldn't
even say attempted home invasion but it
was a home invasion
and was one of the things that we
realized as a family that we needed to
include our kids and our safety plan but
the guy had pushed his way through her
house she came upstairs and said
someone's in our house but she didn't
say hey a guy pushed his way and she
just said dad needs you so something in
me knew something was wrong so I came
downstairs with the firearm to my side
and you know I looked at my husband and
he's like no don't take the shot but I
had it on me and if he would have said
take the shot I would have taken the
shot and ultimately probably would have
ended that guy's life it was a woman who
was in a quite heated argument with I
can only assume as her boyfriend I went
in got my stuff came back out only to
see this woman being thrown by the guy
and the guy walking towards her with a
tire iron really ready to beat the
living crap out of her I pulled my gun
got him to back down and waited until
the cops come to help her out
I had one instance where I was at a
hotel and I came out and there was like
a super creepy note left on my car
saying like I watched you check into the
hotel it was just like really creepy but
I slept like a baby that night because I
knew if anything were to happen
I'm not waiting 8 to 10 minutes for a
police to come to my rescue with their
firearm
[Music]
everybody should have at least the
choice to have it if they want but at
the same time there are people that show
great signs of the propensity to do
something evil and as a gun store owner
we've been able to come in contact with
some folks like that and I've denied
their sale with the quickness like now
you're to me red flags are going off as
I'm talking to you as you're choosing
what you want to purchase and you're
saying things to me that just don't sit
well I've got no problem letting you
walk right out the door and not selling
you a doggone thing particularly one I'm
so happy that we denied that sale
because it came back that this guy had
spent many many months in a mental
institution stole his dad's credit card
to purchase the gun tied up his
caretaker to come to the gun store to
purchase the gun and I again talking to
him and based on training and experience
under this lady I'm standing here by
myself because this is a hard one for me
as well I believe that everybody has a
god-given right to protect themselves
and I guess you know if you do commit a
felony and you lose your rights for the
rest of your life because of felony you
lose your rights for the rest of your
life to purchase firearm I guess you
have to learn other things but then that
just really puts you at a big
disadvantage
three two one
I don't think it's specifically a gun
issue I think it's kind of like a
perfect culmination of all kinds of
things and easier access to gun
ownership is unfortunately one of those
things and it varies from state to state
obviously because you know here in
California it's not the easiest thing to
get a gun
you mentioned easier access yes look you
know in the 1950s you could order a gun
out of a Sears catalog and you could as
a kid you could take your rifle to
school leave it in the coat closet and
then go shoot rabbits after class but we
didn't have mass shootings or school
shootings like we see now if you take if
you take guns completely out of the
issue you know you look there there's an
instance in Japan that I heard somebody
stabbed over a hundred people in one
setting before police were able to
subdue him we're gonna ban knives we're
seeing a mentality a increasing level
depression and mental health issues
that's occurring to our younger
generations and it's rampant but we
don't want to specifically address those
at all we'd rather point add video games
are the problem because look at all the
violence that happens on them or the gun
being the tool if we can just ban them
they'll be gone that's not going to stop
the problem
try to implement the same thing that
Australia did as far as I've taken away
a certain percentage let's see what the
results are as far as crime rate
dropping down like it doesn't need to be
an abundance of weapons I only have one
gun in my house
and one is all I have one gun for work
and one gun for my personal usage you
talk to people who have like 70 80 okay
good for you but why do you need that
many what is one thing and as your
constitutional right to have that but
need I have four different types of
pistols based on the kind of outfit I'm
gonna wear that day I mean am I gonna be
going around with a five-inch long
barrel in my dress NoHo and I'm speaking
more like the macro level like are there
too many guns like in the United States
yes are there too many guns at your
house not necessarily I feel like
America is really baked on getting into
people's business and trying to control
what they can and can't have it's like
saying well you have too many kids well
I want more kids it's gonna be a cold
day in hell before they decide to just
take them away I mean like guns are
about as American as apple pie to be
honest
[Applause]